this graphic seismograph shows the exact
moment at 11 o'clock on the 11th of
November 1918 when the guns on the
Western Front fell silent after four and
a half years of fighting the Great War
was over hours earlier just after 5:00
a.m. that morning Germany had signed an
armistice in a railway carriage north of
Paris the Allies had won from the
trenches of the eep salient to London
Paris and across Europe celebrations
broke out it was a time of relief albeit
surely bittersweet communities villages
and families had been destroyed names of
key battles Passchendaele Jutland the
Somme would enter the national psyche
forevermore I don't think any of us
expected it to resonate quite how it has
resonated with the British population
and of course the reason it's resonated
is because of the personal connections
and the personal stories and people have
been able to identify with what their
great-great grandfather or their
great-great uncle
experienced and that's actually I think
being the case with the British soldiers
and indeed all our servicemen and women
as well who felt it like that the Queen
will lead the country in a special
moment of remembrance at the Cenotaph in
London
she'll be joined on Whitehall by the
German president in 1918 enemies in 2018
strong NATO allies as was the case last
year though Prince Charles will lay a
wreath on his mother's behalf the Duke
of Edinburgh is not expected to attend
veterans will march from Trafalgar
Square to the Senate are as they do
every Remembrance Sunday but this year
they will be joined by 10,000
descendants of soldiers who fought in
the Great War
lucy cubit will be one of them her
grandfather and two great uncles fought
only her grandfather survived it left an
indelible mark on the family so when
you're suddenly in within some two years
lose two of them I mean that's
shattering for any family isn't it the
centenary of World War one prompted Lucy
to put together books for her three
relatives letters regimental documents
photos an enduring record of their
service and sacrifice there's also
stories there's great bravery that's
have been handed on from generation to
generation all sorts of families around
the world who've been part of some of
these conflicts and have given their
children something to look up to the
centenary of World War one has focused
the continent on the events of a century
ago 16 million people on all sides lost
their lives a hundred years on that
hasn't been forgotten
Alastair Bunko Sky News